hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the end is nigh now the
developer of this game is the very same
developer that made Super Meat Boy and
in similar fashion this is a platforming
game that is supposed to be impeccably
difficult incredibly so oh my god that
even looks like Slimer the developer
edmund mcmillen I think that's the name
I I'm not a hundred century also made
Slimer which is one of my favorite flash
games of all time all these platformers
they're gonna be so I need to go get me
some skill at the skill store as a oh
I've got so many wires you guys don't
care about this but I'm tangled in a web
of lies all right here we go
ash dies alone I don't know if that
means hello
hidey-hidey-ho we're gonna load up one
of my favorite games here here we have
the end is nigh it's a classic
old-school platforming game and my
favorites one of my favorite games it's
marvelous fillets that you jumping going
left and right and like always in these
games the spikes
oh no no no no no I'll [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
god no this can't be broke here yeah get
a lot of spit when you're blown in that
cartridge that's definitely gonna help
no it's still not working
oh [ __ ] hey who do you think you are me
I'm the only one that can scream [ __ ] at
that decibel yeah whatever
dear anybody reading this I'm probably
dead
that wouldn't be surprising everybody
else is there was some kind of
apocalypse and all that was left was me
well most of it oh no no hasn't been so
bad till yesterday my favorite game
cartridge finally broke nothing I'm
gonna go out and make a friend I have to
go out there outside no it's a dangerous
twisted
[Music]
death mostly you know what imagine all
the fun we'll have me and my friend you
know collecting tumors spitting teeth
for distance doing right you're
populating the world this won't be easy
but I have nothing left to lose except
my other eye how long all right let's go
out into the world the end is nigh let's
do this we're gonna find a friend that's
the best thing to do so it's a it's a
platformer but also there's more to it
than that but I believe that the
controls are probably gonna be somewhat
similar - oh boy oh boy I know I can't
wall jump um can i oh okay I didn't mean
to do that
I'm sorry hello oh hello hey okay so
it's a similar platformer you y-you want
to be my friend oh it's you must be nice
being live and all that when I died that
tumor wiggled out it's been floating up
there for years watching me please don't
take it it's all I have left
ah I didn't know that was your tumor I
didn't mean to take it from you but I
did okay all right well sorry I took it
you didn't see it though cuz you're dead
when I wasn't dead I used to hang on
corners and stuff just like hanging out
get it please don't die I'll try not to
alright well apparently there are
corners of which which I can hang upon
why would I whoa oh this is good see the
best part about these games is that the
mechanics are actually really tight so
it's punishing but not impossible
and why does it aah I've been dead oh
that's so cool
yeah Catherine absolutely suggested this
game to me and she said that the respawn
mechanics are really really good and
they are oh they're good I love this
it's gonna be infuriating but at least
I'm not gonna be able to blame the
controls on it because the controls in
these games are always good sorry okay
ah okay
well that ain't good but but do Pete
hello when I used to hang off a wall I'd
pull out from it in then I do a jump and
go like super far but when I didn't pull
out words I'd mostly just go up higher I
call it the pullout method I made that
one up two years ago I imagined it would
get more of a laugh please leave me
alone
all right fine sorry that your jokes
aren't funny that is brief air oh no
that's not what I got Frick oh I'm gonna
get you pop up okay going for nice
nailed that perfectly nailed you yeah I
should probably have looked closer to
what I was doing yeah ah shitty dicks
there we go
for Oh all right we're going pretty cool
you don't get away I know I never
finished this game but this reminds me a
lot of rain world and the reason I
didn't finish rain world was because I
actually tried to make another episode
of it but it wasn't exactly what I
wanted out of a ha Frick out of like a
series because the game was like really
long god damn it all right gotta wait
for it to go down
okay well man that respawn is really
smooth but a good thing I'm gonna die so
much all right okay nailed that one to
the wall oh wait I probably need those
maybe I'll be able to come back and go
yes I will
no no no no boots Bob whoa I know my god
her okay I'm watching you oh I gotcha
nice all right where does this row why
am i upon the clouds and why is that
tumor so big poop hey yo poopd ba freak
anyway yeah so rain world wasn't what I
wanted out of a long series so that's
why I didn't finish that one and just
left it at the one episode but anyway
we've got places to go so enough meat
talking about my failures oh nice okay
so there's gotta be a way oh it's gonna
fall down then I'm gonna go up I got it
excuse me pardon be there anything I can
eat from here no PUD
will do okay how do I get to you mmm all
right fine I'll come back for you later
I got other people that need my
attention right meow oh no oh no that's
not what I wanted
let's try that again yep deep okay up up
up
nope hang on the corner there oh yeah I
can do this pop yep
hope hep pop nice nice I nailed that one
poop T all right God I got it got it I'm
getting all the tumors I don't even know
what I'm supposed to be doing with him
but I got him oh boy hey oh I saw you
well how am I supposed to get you I have
no idea how I'm supposed to get you I
can't even get up there well that's
gonna be nothing to me so I gotta keep
moving approaches okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] but okay we're fine
no no yeah Oh what is that there's
something up there hang on pop something
up there nope
oh there's got to be a way oh yes okay I
don't know what oh I find a lot of
secret areas not that they're
necessarily hard to find in the
beginning of the phase but maybe there's
gonna be something hi buddy
maybe there's gonna be something worth
it if I find it all hey I don't like
that I can't I'm on the wrong side to
get up you well doesn't matter anyway I
wasn't gonna get you up we're at kaduk
okay OOP there we go
oh oh oh not that just a little up huh
there we go okay ah
titty Dix okay oh boy no I made it ma I
was dead for sure why does it gotta be
like that Oh God
okay it's fine everything's good even
though everything is crumbling to dust
around will nope you uh-oh
ha ha ha I don't like that how am I
supposed to do this how do i oh okay um
I may be stupid here but I don't see I
ain't seeing the way to go about that
cuz I can't old Oh
oh I forgot that you can hang on a
corner of even where a spike is okay I
went in a butt hole all right well
secret over I guess butt hole through
done and done get you off ready okay ah
that ain't good that ain't good that
ain't good that ain't good okay we're
good oh yeah no not forever I thought
you were forever alright this game is
giving me odds des but I'm fine ah
that's not gonna work I thought I had
time I thought I had more time where
that is dick so what do I do there's
gotta be like uh there's gotta be some
secret use about that right hope nope
that ain't it that ain't it use so what
is this whoa all right bye
what are you doing where am I going well
I'm a tunnel ooh oh hi hello baby
are you a baby what are you what are you
even I don't even know what you is welp
I just ate you so okay how do I need to
eat the tumor babies that makes no sense
yep
nope okay but I can't just I can't just
go for that cuz I'll slam right into
that thing
hey I can't go any farther oh maybe it's
like it's a race against time
ah that's what it is okay so I don't
need a freak
ah interesting so yeah you can get
through just fine with that but then
you're screwed so is there any way to
get by without doing it yes there is I
see it I see the way I see the solution
so what you got to do is you got to go
over here do all this hunky dunky
[ __ ] get over here get over here get
over Yang and yang Ying you lalalalala
give me the baby okay then you go up
here jump up oh not not quite right
there John back jump jump and then go
yeah and then you got of tumor for sale
which is great
Wow again slam the body into the spikes
there felt good
okay that hurt is well goddamn it why do
I keep going full blast they stop
shooting off full blast oh okay made it
don't have a key yeah there's a secret
probably that I missed all Frick how
about we just how we wait because it
seems like there's a perfectly
reasonable way to go up here Oh missed
it okay but I can do that if I hang on
the edge probably be able to get where I
need to go hey I'm gonna hang on I'm
gonna damn its way there's a well
there's way there's way and a will I got
wills and I got ways nope no no don't
get caught on the douche 'try douche no
not on the douche a tree ah up and over
and get on the lip get up oh god it's so
close but if I could just get on the lip
on the first try then I wouldn't be
eating dick get on the lip
yes made it nailed it where is this oh
cloud I can get on the guy cloud please
no don't betray me ah
Frick hey buddy yeah okay huh
okay made that ooh daddy's disturbing
how do I get up there I gotta get up top
interasante
but I don't know if there's gonna be
enough lift yeah I need just a bit more
I need to somehow be hanging off one of
those edges before it even comes down
you know what I mean all right there's
got to be okay I think what I got to do
is I got to get this thing to fall down
there goes weirdly enough god dammit god
dammit gods yeah back okay [ __ ] you oh
we're gonna get angry in this one are we
up too high oh I didn't get enough
horizontal I would have had that if I
would have the horizontal launch or it
didn't give it to me why didn't he give
it to me come on come on come on come on
you sack of [ __ ] wow I'm gonna get you
[Music]
oh no haha I got you
hello wow we sure are high aren't we so
high in fact I think I can make out your
fate from here you you're going to make
a mistake you will create something that
will come back to haunt you I can see a
pile of bones something about cancer
wait who are you why do I share your
memories I'm trippin out man are you my
ghost see if I can land up Oh
frickin dick I was gonna
[Music]
goddamnit I was gonna want know I [ __ ]
it have I [ __ ] it haven't I
I have thoroughly [ __ ] it god damn it
right I gotta go get more hey c'mere
baby oh this seems big arias I know I
forgot that was temporary
oh I'm too pretty okay I have no bones
okay gotcha
just one oh no hit - alright gotta wait
long enough
yippee oh yes oh yeah oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no that's not
enough time I know what I gotta do I
know what I gotta do I know what I gotta
do I know it's got a sick maneuver oh I
am the best at walking up Rick Rick my
dick my dick my ass
I hate doing that what I do is I hit it
with my head before I'm ready to give no
how do my scoots crus you had it
perfectly and then I forked it up yeah
no I want the edge I want the edge you
know I want the team ads you okay don't
[ __ ] it up
no no I [ __ ] it off Rick okay but I
can do more if I do if I do more edge
work should be able if I get really good
at the edge work okay I didn't even need
work I am that good no no no I don't
care what you do I don't care who we are
I'm not gonna let you oh that was almost
a mistake but I made it
cuz I'm cool cuz I'm really really
really really cool I'll get you I'll
come back for you
hey oh we did good we made it hey bonesy
oh hey
them's the remains of our ancestors down
there their guts all connected
underground why at night I can hear them
scream whispering help us we're burning
in hell or something like that
it's hard to hear them over my own
screams anyway it's like some kind of
tunnel system so when you find a new one
to remove the scab hop in boom you're
home all right Thank You creepy old pile
of bones so anyway this has been the end
is nigh I really like this game I always
liked platformers like this I mean even
though you know as far as like the story
it's always hard to discern from a
platformer standpoint I am very curious
about this world and what it means that
all these people are dead and why their
ancestors are connected in an
underground network that you travel
through after ripping thus crabs off and
also they're burning in hell so we'll
see how that goes so thank you everybody
so much for watching I am gonna play
more of this but let me know if you like
it I wanna really know so look down in
the comments
for that and thanks again for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]